the host of the Ross Tucker football
podcast and host of the new radio.com
show home and home at 8:00 a.m. Monday
through Friday Ross will be part of the
Seahawks Eagles pregame show Sunday 4
WIP in Philly Ross great to have you on
how are you Dan I am fantastic thanks
for having me as always I am in New
Orleans I got UCF at Tulane tomorrow for
CBS Sports Network then I go back to
Philly for the Eagles Seahawks oh these
are my Falls Dan it's a tough job
somebody's got to do it I love it man
keep you busy that's the way that's the
way you you know advance in this
business I mentioned this you know the
top of the show what I do know is I
don't know anything about this miles
Garrett Mason Rudolph situation and
nobody's gonna back down on either side
and this will lead to speculation now
we're gonna read in and we're gonna
figure out well why something happened
or didn't happen why something was said
not said who heard it who'd said it did
anybody say anything what do you take
away from this well it's an awful
situation right because either had
happened and we all agree that that
should never happen in any way shape or
form or it didn't happen and this is a
false allegation that about as bad of an
allegation as you can make of any human
being so it's an awful situation no
matter how you look at it Dan somebody
is lying and you know the issue for me
is I guess twofold right number one as
it relates to Miles Garrett I was about
as defensive of him as anyone because I
actually had that happen to me in a
practice one time Lavar Arrington got my
helmet off and swung it at me thank
goodness he missed but I can see how it
happened because I was part of it and I
applauded miles Garrett for his
accountability after the game I said
look things happen you lose your mind
it's not okay he'll be suspended for the
rest of year and he should well I didn't
think it was as awful as everybody else
did I could see how that would happen
and I applaud his accountability how can
I do
now dinner how can i how can I stand up
for Garrett's accountability on multiple
levels number one I find it really hard
to believe that if there was a racial
slur that he wouldn't have mentioned
that after the game you know you have to
think 99.9% of human beings would have
said look I lost my cool he said
something that was unacceptable I still
shouldn't have lost my cool but then
there's the second part of it which is
that he obviously was throwing it out
there at the appeal hearing but it
doesn't really condone his behavior
right like even if that did happen it's
not okay and it's horrible but that
doesn't make it okay that Garrett hit
him on the head with the helmet so it's
like yeah I don't know I know what he
was going for but even if it happened it
didn't work as now a member like oh he
did okay then no suspension you're right
that's fine he shouldn't have said that
it's still not okay to hit the guy in
there with the helmet no matter what he
says yeah but I think people are still
condoning it if it's based off of that
you know that that maybe that either
Rudolf or one of his teammates said
something to miles Garrett and you know
not that I look at it and say boy I'm
gonna lessen your suspension I would
look at that separately you still
grabbed his helmet and you still hit a
guy over the head with his helmet
I you know I Rudolf should be punished
in this situation but this speculation
makes me nervous because you know what's
the NFL do do you have lie detector test
like what's next here to try to figure
this out because it does feel like you
know I gave three options Garrett's
lying
Rudolph's lying and said something
Garrett misheard something is there
anything else that you can throw in
there as far as options go no I don't
think so and and to your point number
one I said all week I felt like Mason
Rudolph should have been suspended one
game
if Ogun Jobi was suspended one game for
hitting Rudolph in the back then Rudolph
for trying to rip Miles Garrett's helmet
off on the field and then after his
helmet was off and two offensive lineman
you know keeping miles Garrett away
Rudolph went over and escalated the
situation again and I only by the way
Dan had one rule when I got in football
fights which is if my helmet came off I
was out for me I was done Rudolph is
evidently not been in fights because
once your helmets off it's over but I'll
take it a step further than you know if
I'm Rudolph I take a lie-detector test
and maybe both of them but I almost
wonder if this backfires on miles
Garrett the NFL has come out and said
they found no credible evidence if if
they don't believe that Mason Rudolph
said that and this is now based on Miles
Garrett's Twitter statement a public
accusation of a racial slur doesn't the
indefinite suspension go on longer like
if they don't if they think Miles
Garrett's lying doesn't that doesn't
have to be some discipline for that I
think it's dangerous to go down that
slope though I understand what you're
saying but I'm gonna just punish him for
his actions and you know Rudolph should
be punished as well we're talking to
Ross Tucker Westwood one NFL analyst and
a host of new radio.com show home and
home at 8:00 a.m. Monday through Friday
if I said now that there was no team
labeled Americas team and I said let's
just put it out there who is America's
team right now who do you think would be
America's team it's very close between
the Patriots and the Cowboys now look
the Packers and Steelers also have
incredible fan bases and I can tell you
from playing for five teams at any time
the Packers or the Steelers came to town
it felt like there was a lot of fans of
the other team but when I was with the
Cowboys band in 2002 we were 5 and 11 we
were terrible I would go to the hotel
then there'd be like hundreds of people
at the team hotel hundreds and it wasn't
like that for the Redskins it wasn't
like that for the Bills was like that
for the Patriots even when I was there
hundreds of people I remember thinking
like today no we stink like do they know
we're terrible I didn't matter
we were the Dallas Cowboys and I think
the Patriots are now there you know I
can't tell you how many little kids I
know my nephew lives outside of DC and
for a couple of years we was like six or
seven he was a Redskins fan you know
whose team is Patriots Patriots fans and
Tom Brady fans are now everywhere and so
I think this is going to break the
ratings for a 4:25 Sunday game because
these are by far the two most watched
teams and I think the two teams that
really are competing to be America's
team and right now I think you might
have to lean to the Patriots just in the
sense that anything that goes on with
them gets even more attention to the
Cowboys now this Antonio Brown stuff I
talked to Kristen Fourier this morning
anything that goes on with the Patriots
even gets more national attention and
the Cowboys now so I guess on some level
it's the Patriots but do you have to
like America's team like it it feels
like more people don't like the Patriots
they're they're polarizing so I don't
know what constitutes and like what what
makes you America's team because you
make more headlines more people are
interested in in what you do good or bad
I think I think America's team is just
the team that gets the most attention
because I'm from outside of Philadelphia
and everybody hates the Cowboys with a
passion hates them well because of the
evils of the mystique of America team
right all the Eagles fans hate the
Cowboys with a passion so even though
the Cowboys have been labeled America's
Team for years you know Redskins fans
hate em cowboy Giants fans hate them
almost everybody hates the Cowboys other
than Cowboys fans and the Patriots are
the only other NFL team that I could
think of that have gotten to this point
where you're either a Patriots fan or
you hate the Patriots it really feels
like it is that
way and maybe they've overcome the
Cowboys but it's like the Yankees in
baseball and it's now the Cowboys and
Patriots and what's weird about that Dan
is it feels like the Cowboys were always
that way the Yankees were always that
way I'm not sure I could think of
another team since I've been around that
became that like while I was watching it
they became America's team
over the last 18 years and I think it's
proof that the Cowboys are America's
Team if you're 5 and 11 and people are
waiting in line to get your autograph
when you played for the Cowboys I think
that's the confirmation the Cowboys are
American that if we ever needed any
evidence people waiting in line at hotel
to get the the best left guard to start
the last seven games of the 2002 season
in Cowboys history you're great have a
great weekend safe travels there Ross we
appreciate your time as always all right
thank you so much dad that's Ross Tucker
Westwood one NFL analyst form NFL player
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]